we had a small group national security
meeting today with the president and the
vice president about the latest
provocation on the Korean Peninsula
we have many military options and
president wanted to be briefed on each
one of them we made clear that we have
the ability to defend ourselves and our
allies South Korea and Japan from any
attack and our commitments among the
Allies are ironclad any threat to the
United States or its territories
including Guam or our allies will be met
with a massive military response a
response both effective and overwhelming
King jung-hoon should take heed the
United Nations Security Council's
unified voice all members unanimously
agreed on the threat North Korea poses
and they remain unanimous and their
commitment to the denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula because we are not
looking to the total annihilation of a
country namely North Korea but as I said
we have many options to do so thank you
very much Leighton gentlemen